>>> BOB WOODRD HAS WRITTEN FOR
DECADES ABOUT PRESIDENTS AND FOR
YEARS ABOUT DONALD TRUMP'S
CAVALIER ATTITUDE TOWARD
NATIONAL SECURITY, FROM
DISCUSSING ON THE GOLF COURSE A
DRONE STRIKE ON AN IRANIAN
GENERAL TO THE IDEA OF PULLING
OUT OF A TRADE DEAL WITH SOUTH
KOREA.
BUT THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT
HEARING DONALD TRUMP OPENLY
DISCUSSING NUCLEAR WEAPONS
SYSTEMS, LIKE THIS.
>> I HAVE BUILT A WEAPON SYSTEM
LIKE NOBODY'S HAD IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WE'VE HAD STUFF THAT YOU HAVE
NEVER SEEN OR HEARD ABOUT
BEFORE.
WE HAVE STUFF THAT PUTIN AND XI
HAVE NEVER HEARD ABOUT BEFORE.
>> YOU LOOKED INTO IT WHEN TRUMP
TOLD YOU THAT.
ONE OF YOUR SOURCES TOLD YOU HE
WAS SURPRISED TRUMP HAD
DISCLOSED THE EXISTENCE OF THIS
WEAPONS SYSTEM TO YOU.
>> YEAH, I FINALLY HEARD FROM
SOMEBODY WHAT IT WAS, AND IT'S
TRUE.
XI AND PUTIN WOULD NOT KNOW
ABOUT IT.
BUT WHY IS TRUMP BRAGGING ABOUT
IT?
AGAIN, IT'S JUST THIS -- WHAT'S
THE JOB OF THE PRESIDENT?
THE JOB OF THE PRESIDENT IS TO
FIGURE OUT -- I ONCE SAID TO
TRUMP BECAUSE HE WAS KIND OF
ASKING, WHAT DO YOU THINK THE
PRESIDENT'S JOB IS?
AND I SAID, IT IS TO ASCERTAIN
THE NEXT STAGE OF GOOD FOR A
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTRY, NOT ONE PARTY OR A
BUNCH OF INTEREST GROUPS, AND
THEN DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE
PLAN AND EXECUTE IT.
AND HE SAID, OH, THAT'S GOOD.
THAT'S GREAT.
NEVER DID HE DO THIS.
AND YOU KNOW, YOU CAN TELL IN
THE TONE OF MY VOICE AND
OVERPERSISTENCE OF WHAT I'M
SAYING, THIS IS DANGEROUS.
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
IN THE MOST SERIOUS WAY.
>> YEAH.
AND HIS DISCLOSING THAT TO YOU
CERTAINLY PUTS A NEW LIGHT ON
HIM HAVING ALL THOSE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS IN MAR-A-LAGO FOR
YEARS.
I ALSO WANT TO PLAY THIS
EXCHANGE YOU HAD, THIS ODD
EXCHANGE YOU HAD WITH DONALD
TRUMP ABOUT KIM JONG-UN.
LET'S ROLL THAT TAPE.
>> THE CIA SAYS ABOUT KIM
JONG-UN THAT HE'S CUNNING,
CRAFTY, BUT ULTIMATELY STUPID.
>> I DISAGREECHLT HE'S CUNNING.
HE'S CRAFTY.
BUT HE'S VERY SMART.
>> WHY DOES THE CIA SAY THAT?
>> BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW,
OKAY?
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA.
I'M THE ONLY ONE WHO KNOWS.
I'M THE ONLY ONE HE DEALS WITH.
HE WON'T DEAL WITH ANYBODY ELSE.
THE WORD CHEMISTRY.
YOU MEET SOMEBODY, YOU HAVE GOOD
CHEMISTRY.
YOU MEET A WOMAN, IN ONE SECOND
YOU KNOW WHETHER OR NOT IT'S ALL
GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> AND IS THIS ALL DRIVING KIM
TO THE NEGOTIATING TABLE?
>> NO, NO.
IT WAS DESIGNED FOR WHATEVER
REASON.
IT WAS DESIGNED INSTINCTIVELY.
I'M TRYING TO LISTEN WITH AN
OPEN MIND.
YOU KNOW, MAYBE HE UNDERSTANDS
SOMETHING THE CIA DOESN'T.
CERTAINLY THEY GET THINGS WRONG
ALL THE TIME, BUT HE DOESN'T
PROVIDE ANY INFORMATION.
AND THEN YOU'RE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND.
SO, YOU'RE SAYING THIS ABOUT KIM
JONG-UN AND YOU HAVE THIS
CHEMISTRY AND THE PURPOSE IS
WHAT?
AND HE SAYS IT WAS DESIGNED FOR
WHATEVER REASON.
IT WAS DESIGNED, WHO KNOWS,
INSTINCTIVELY.
LET'S TALK INSTINCT.
THERE'S NO SUBSTANCE THERE AT
ALL.
>> AND HERE HE'S SAYING HIS
DECISION IS INSTINCT.
AND I KIND OF DON'T -- I MEAN,
WHAT A CASUAL WAY, AS I POINT
OUT IN ONE OF MY 200
COMMENTARIES IN THE AUDIO BOOK,
THIS TRAUMATIZED HIS NATIONAL
SECURITY TEAM.
KIM JONG-UN, THE THUGGISH LEADER
OF NORTH KOREA HAD NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
HE HAD MISSILES THAT HE GOT
FROM -- MISSILE LAUNCHERS FROM
CHINA.
AND THEN HE CONCEALED THEM AND
HE HID THEM IN A WAY THAT THE
CIA WAS, MY GOD, THIS GUY, IF WE
EVER HAVE TO HAVE A WAR OR SOME
SORT OF NUCLEAR EXCHANGE WITH
HIM, HE'S REALLY ADVANCED.
AND THE DEFENSE SECRETARY,
MATTIS, USED TO SLEEP IN HIS GYM
CLOTHES BECAUSE HE KNEW IF A
MISSILE WAS COMING TO THE UNITED
STATES HE WOULD BE CALLED TO AN
EMERGENCY CONFERENCE.
AND I ASKED TRUMP ABOUT THIS.
TRUMP HAD GIVEN THE AUTHORITY TO
MATTIS TO SHOOT DOWN AN INCOMING
MISSILE LIKE THAT.
MATTIS WAS GOING TO THE NATIONAL
CATHEDRAL TO PRAY, TO MAKE PEACE
WITH HIS GOD, THAT HAS DEFENSE
SECRETARY, HE MIGHT HAVE TO USE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS TO DEFEND OUR
COUNTRY.
AND THIS, THE PRESIDENT'S
PRESENTATION ON THIS IS, WELL,
IT'S INSTINCT.
WHO KNOWS?
I MEAN, COME ON.
I BAFFLE -- I AM INCREASINGLY
BAFFLED THE MORE I HEAR THE
CASUAL DISCONNECT, THE SENSE HE
HAS OF OBLIGATION TO HIMSELF, I
GUESS, I MEAN, ABOUT KIM
JONG-UN.
I'M THE ONLY ONE THAT KNOWS.
I MEAN, COME ON.
I'VE NEVER HEARD -- I'VE
INTERVIEWED LOTS OF PRESIDENTS
AND PEOPLE THAT WORK WITH THEM
AND GOT NOTES AND TRANSCRIPTS OF
MEETINGS IN THE WHITE HOUSE --
NEVER HEARD ANOTHER PRESIDENT
SAY ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
LOTS OF BIG EGOS IN THE
PRESIDENCY.
>> RIGHT, FOR SURE.
>> NEVER HEARD ONE SAY, I -- I'M
THE ON